hey guys I hope you're all staying
healthy safe and occupied before we
start I would just like to send out my
thoughts and wishes to anyone who may be
affected by this ongoing crisis and I
hope that all of the brave doctors
scientists researchers and people around
the world can come together and work
together to solve this crisis and
problem as soon as possible and so that
some people had a little bit of
difficulty getting their origami
boomerangs to work and while many people
liked the video and said that they were
able to get it to work I still wanted to
come up with something that was easy to
make choirs know origami knowledge at
all and flies just as great so I came up
with a cardboard tri-blade boomerang
that you can make by cutting out a
cereal box or other thin cardboard that
you might have lying around the house
it's gonna take a little bit of
adjustment and practice but once you get
the hang of it you're gonna have hours
of fun now I am going to show you how to
throw it at the very end of the video
and adjust it so be sure to watch that
and don't skip it if you do enjoy the
tutorial for the boomerang be sure to
give it a thumbs up or like down below
and also leave me a comment letting me
know what you thought don't forget to
click the subscribe and notification
bell also so you know when I come out
with new content and for those of you
wondering how it flies here's a quick
clip of me throwing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to make the boomerang we're going to
need a thin piece of cardboard at least
six inches by six inches a ruler pencil
and some scissors I found the best
cardboard to use is the thin types that
they use in cereal boxes popcorn boxes
cracker boxes whatever you might have
thicker cardboard doesn't work as well
so if you bend the cardboard like this
back and forth and it kind of wrinkles
like this it's probably a little bit too
thick so I don't recommend you try it
regular paper doesn't work that well
though it does come back in a small
circle it's too light and flimsy though
I haven't tried cardstock or cover paper
so if you try it and it works let me
know in the comments once you have all
this you're ready to go when you open
the top and bottom of the box you should
notice there's a little lip here where
you can just kind of pull it apart and
then you can cut it at one of the folds
in the box that way you have two
sections which you can then make two
boomerangs with now we can just remove
the excess by just cutting it off we're
going to start out by drawing an
equilateral triangle that has three
centimetres sides and a two point five
centimeter height since equilateral
means all sides are the same every side
should measure three centimetres when
we're finished if your cardboard has two
longer sides like mine then we could
just turn it so the longer edges are
vertical and then we could start drawing
right near the middle just place the
ruler in the middle of the paper and
draw a three centimeter horizontal line
just like that and now we could place a
mark in the middle of the line at the
one point five centimeter measurement
this will split the line in half as you
could see here
holding the ruler perpendicular to the
line we can now draw upwards from the
midpoint to the two and a half
centimeter measurement so place the edge
of the ruler vertically on the halfway
point we made and continue up until you
reach two point five just like that to
finish the triangle we just need to
connect the two bottom ends of the
horizontal line to the top of the
vertical one and there you go you've
done an equilateral triangle now we're
going to draw three lines from the point
of the triangle directly out through the
middle of the opposite triangle side or
base each line will be 3.75 or 3 and 3/4
inches long and we will make a mark on
the line at the 3 inch measurement since
we already have a mark on the bottom
side halfway point we just need to make
a mark on the other two I usually just
eyeball it but if you want to you can
use a ruler so right about there and
there so we can now draw a line from the
point out through the base here that's 3
and 3/4 inches and making a mark at that
3 inch point draw a 3 and 3/4 inch line
and make a mark at 3 inches now that
we've completed this one we could do the
remaining 2
you should have something that looks
just like this now we're now going to
draw three two inch wide lines which
will lay directly on the last mark that
we made at the three inch point take the
ruler and place the 1-inch measurement
directly on the existing line and the
mark that we previously made then you
could draw a line from the zero to the
two inch measurement making sure it is
perpendicular to the existing line then
just do the same for the other two now
all we need to do is just connect the
edges of the two-inch line with the
corners of the triangle that it faces on
all three sides trying to be as neat as
possible draw a line from the corner of
the triangle here to the end of the
two-inch line continue to do the same
until you have six lines total and it
looks something like the diagram I
showed
to complete the overall outline of the
boomerang we just need to draw a
semicircle that goes from one end of the
two-inch line to the other touching the
end of the central lines as shown here I
do this part purely by eye but if you
are not good at drawing semi circles
then you can use possibly like a piece
of tape or some sort of cap it doesn't
really matter you just need to make a
semicircle just like that
so I'm just gonna do it by hand so I'm
just gently drawing a curved line from
the edge of the two-inch wide line over
the top of the central line so that it
looks like semicircle in EIU's shape and
then you could do the same with the
other two so it should look something
like that
lastly we just need to draw the line for
the airfoil holding each arm of the
boomerang downwards it's drawn from the
very bottom point to the bottom right
corner of the central triangle we're
going to draw a line from the very
bottom point to the bottom-right corner
of the triangle just like this line it
up as best you can and draw the line and
this area here that I'm filling in is
going to be folded downwards to provide
the airfoil rotate it so that the next
arm is down and do the same exact thing
and then finally do the same with the
last one and we're all done all we need
to do is to cut it out and fold it and
I'll show you how to throw it if you
guys got here you did really well your
true artists and excellent job there's
no real right way to cut it just make
sure you take your time stay within the
lines here and that you don't bend it
too much I like to start from the
outside and work my way into the corners
first usually just like this and then
from the other side and then you could
twist that piece off and if there's a
little bit of excess in the middle you
can just rub it with the corner of the
scissors then just cut around and just
work your way around the whole thing
whichever way you like and then you can
work your way again once again into the
corners just like that from each side
and then twist off the piece and just
smooth it out in between the corner of
the blades do the same thing and just
make sure you've gotten everything
we are now done cutting we are done
measuring we just need to fold along the
airfoil lines and make some adjustments
and we are ready to throw it to fold the
airfoil you can use a variety of
different objects from the edge of a
table or preferably the pointy edge of a
street metal object like a ruler or a
pair of scissors like I am it doesn't
have to be that sharp so there's no need
to use anything sharp enough to cut
yourself line up the edge of the object
you're using with the line that you've
drawn in the cardboard holding the
scissors firmly in place on the line I'm
going to first fold upwards creasing the
cardboard all the way to the corner of
the blades as you can see right here
where my pointer finger is now that I
have an existing crease as you could see
on the line I can now fold it downwards
once again making sure that the crease
goes from the end of the boomerang all
the way to the middle now the airfoil is
facing away from us and you could do the
same with the rest of them so do the
same thing lift up against the edge of
the metal and then fold back down lift
it up and then fold on that existing
crease once again so we finished folding
the airfoils but as you can see they're
folded pretty far down we do not want
them folded this far down so set it down
on the table and just press down gently
so now we're finally ready to do a test
flight so let's see how it flies I'm
gonna take the boomerang and I'm going
to hold it so that the face we just
completed is facing towards us and I'm
going to take my middle finger and thumb
and grab right here below this little
line right here and put my finger on top
of this edge right here where the
airfoil is and I'm going to just first
practice throwing it you want to throw
it like a frisbee except you want to let
it roll off the tip of your finger so
it's important to really get a good
flick of the wrist and make sure that
it's spinning a lot so let's practice
the spin first you want to go like this
and spin it a couple times so try to
spin it like that
give it enough spin and you'll see it
should come back actually even if you
throw it horizontally
just like that
so the same thing we're going to try now
to throw it sideways so that it spins
around we're gonna hold it the same way
between our thumb and middle finger and
put our pointer finger on top hold it so
that this side is facing to the right
and angle it ever so slightly to the
left maybe it like an 80 degree angle
and you're gonna flick your wrist
outwards letting it roll off the tip of
your finger let's try it just like that
so this one's working pretty well now
again make sure that these are not bent
too much if you bend them too much this
is what will happen it will not fly very
fast because it's blocking too much air
it's not getting a lot of it's getting
too much air resistance so you see how
slow it goes so once again if you bent
them too much like this just set it down
on the table and just flatten it out
like that make sure you're holding it
properly put your pointer on top here
hold it like this angle it ever so
slightly and flick your wrist out flick
your wrist and let it roll off your
finger
[Music]
and there you go there is your cardboard
boomerang thank you guys so much for
watching my tutorial for the cardboard
tri-blade boomerang I hope you did enjoy
it and found it easy to follow
especially since I put a lot of work
into it with all the diagrams and
everything and I think it's a really
cool way to use excess cardboard that
you might have otherwise thrown away
I've been posting some stuff on my
Instagram and also my Rob's phone
channel so if you haven't checked those
channels out I'll definitely put some
links down below to my other social
media sites that you can check out that
I've been using a couple of people have
asked me about cubing and I actually
recently got some new cubes
I got again 3x3 and 4x4 magnetic and
also MOU 5x5 all of which have become my
favorite new cubes and I recently got a
sub 5 for all three of them which is
pretty that's really good for me
considering I've only been practicing
for a few weeks again please give the
video a thumbs up if you enjoyed it and
let me know what you'd like to see next
down in the comments below I do have
some other ideas that I've been writing
down some other origami stuff and some
non-related origami things that I've
been thinking about teaching but I just
wasn't sure people would actually want
to see it so you know maybe I'll do that
so I might put a pole up and see if you
guys want to see some of the things that
I am thinking about so I'll definitely
do my best to post more even if it's
just an update or cube solving video or
whatever it is something that I've been
wanting to teach so definitely be on the
lookout and I'll see you that